for more on all of this let's bring in
our Dr David agus good morning Dr agus
how are you doing
good morning Nate I'm all right
I wish we had you here under better
circumstances but your knowledge is
needed in moments like this the Buffalo
Bills confirmed in a statement that
demore Hamlin suffered cardiac arrest
his heartbeat was restored on the field
and he's currently in critical condition
what does all of this mean to you
well you saw that tackle in that tackle
the the opponent's helmet was in his
chest so he had blunt force trauma to
the chest and an exact right spot at the
exact right moment during his heartbeat
it caused his heart to have what we call
an arrhythmia not beat effectively to
push blood to the brain so he stood up
not enough blood went to the brain he
fell down and that heart was in
vitricular fibrillation well we know
with this committed quartus which is
this condition is that every minute you
delay
shocking them resuscitating them what
happens is there's an increase of 10
percent of mortality they started CPR
right away which is great My Hope Is
they were able to restore the heart rate
soon enough to be able to get blood flow
to the brain so there's no damage there
so the question Dr Vegas is how common
are hits like this that have the
potential to stop an individual's heart
and how much time you talked about
oxygen to his brain they were they they
got his heart beating on the field but
he's still breathing uh on a ventilator
he's not breathing on his own so what
does that tell you
so there are about 30 of these cases a
year that happened to the United States
they predominantly happen in kids it
happens during Little League Baseball a
ball is thrown by a pitcher and hits the
person in the chest it happens in soccer
where there's something that causes that
blunt force trauma so remarkably rare
the fact that he's not breathing on his
own certainly makes me worried because
the sooner you are able to shock him
back into a normal Rhythm the sooner you
can go back to everything working and
that fact that he's not breathing on his
own me tell me there's some brain damage
and I'm over interpreting here I think
that's clear but we're going to know a
lot over the next 12 to 24 hours as they
start to turn down the machine that's
breathing for him the ventilator to see
if he can breathe his on his own and our
hopes and prayers are that he can
Dr akas if it was the condition that you
mentioned you mentioned it's extremely
rare but should there be more scrutiny
on player safety there's a lot of focus
on brain injuries but should there be
more focus on the impact of these
tackles on other parts of the body
listen I think in All Sport we start
have to re-look at safety when a child
hits a soccer ball once you see MRI
changes of inflammation in the brain in
these kids in football we're seeing lots
of injuries you know the artificial turf
is changing they're getting more
athletic the game is changing and when
we do that we start to have to look can
we protect the athletes better these
athletes as we saw last night put their
lives on the line for our entertainment
and it's the obligation I think of all
of us to make sure they're protected as
much as they can be
Dr David agus thank you for joining us
this morning
thank you
you know this is um it's unfortunate
and that the players had to witness this
coaches
fans in the stadium but also fans at
home
you know as players we come to grips
that
the injury rate in the NFL is 100 let me
repeat that you will get injured it's
inevitable and and you are when you
decide to play this game you take that
knowing that that could happen when I
write my signature down I understand
that but we struggle to wrestle with is
that it could be worse and oftentimes
we avoid it Escape by 11 years for me
I've had broken bones toward ligaments
I've done it all concussions all the way
down to my pinky toes I've heard
everything on my body
but your worst nightmare is what we saw
last night we just hope that he recovers
and we're praying for him and his family
as well we are praying for him his
family and the fans who are coming out
and turning out to support them is a
wonderful thing and we'll talk a little
bit more about this